[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue 4 éditorialiste intellectuelle de
talent pour commenter quatre sujets
comme chaque jour 4 suggère qu'on
découvre en images tout de suite
patronat et syndicats ont entamé
aujourd'hui des discussions sur la
réforme du chômage il faut trouver de
l'argent il ya 35 milliards de dette
eh bien nous on a des idées pour faire
des économies on va vous les soumettre
et puis on verra bien si nos
intervenants sont d'accord on va parler
aussi du budget italien pour 2019 qui a
été refusé par la commission européenne
rome dépense trop estime bruxelles mais
est ce que bruxelles va trop loin
on essaiera de répondre à cette question
on parlera aussi de sofia chikhi roux
qui fut la directrice de la
communication de la campagne de jean-luc
mélenchon
elle était hier sur bfm tv vous at elle
convaincu on en parlera et puis on
parlera des perles et père de famille
qui reviennent dans l'actualité
est ce qu'on en a encore besoin on en
parle à l'occasion de par exemple des
violences scolaires qui sont souvent le
fait d'enfants sans père ou bien
évidemment à l'occasion de l'ouverture
possible de la procréation médicalement
assistée aux couples de femmes
quatre invités pour débattre de ces
sujets bonsoir annuel de maresquel ravis
de vous accueillir vous êtes historien
il est notamment l'auteur d'une
formidable biographie de fouché entre
autres livres vous êtes éditeur vous
êtes membre du comité de rédaction de la
revue des deux mondes est votre dernier
livre le temps de s'en apercevoir vient
d'être publié aux éditions de
l'iconoclaste thomas guénolé bonsoir
mais ce sera vous êtes politologue
membres de la france insoumise vous êtes
d'ailleurs co responsable de l'école de
ce mouvement car je crois que ce n'est
pas un parti la france est un mouvement
effet c'est un mouvement est votre
dernier livre anti sociale la guerre
sociale est déclarée a été publié chez
plon
christian makarian bonsoir soit vous
êtes directeur délégué de la rédaction
de l'express notre excellent confrère
qui publie cette semaine un en
couverture un dossier sur moi ben ben
salman le tyran qui a dupé l'occident et
puis renaud girard est là aussi bon soit
renault vous êtes le chroniqueur
international du figaro êtes vous aussi
membre du comité de rédaction de la
revue des deux mondes d'ailleurs je
crois comme votre voisin est votre
dernier livre qu'elle diplomatie pour la
france prendre les réalités telles
qu'elles sont a été publié aux éditions
du seuil
r on commence avec un sujet sérieux mais
on va essayer d'en parler de façon
concrète le chômage puisque les
discussions commencent aujourd'hui sur
la réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
est en déficit chronique alors voici n
est pas trop généraliste je vais vous
proposer des projets de réforme
ils sont un peu libéraux parce qu on ne
se refait pas mais vous allez me dire si
vous êtes d'accord ou pas on va s'y de
se comparer avec d'autres pays pour voir
s'il ya des pistes de réformes possibles
alors commençons par la durée d'activité
minimale pour avoir droit au chômage
alors en france quatre mois suffisent
alors que en allemagne il faut avoir
travaillé un an pour avoir droit au
chômage même si ces quatre mois c'est un
peu sous conditions parce que ces gens
n'entrent pas dans les détails mais on
va dire que c'est plus facile en france
d'avoir droit au chômage en allemagne
christian makarian est ce que ce serait
l'occasion pour inciter les gens à
retravailler de d'allonger la durée
minimum de travail avant d'avoir droit
au chômage
oui si c'est inclus dans un plan global
lot 6 et d'une région ponctuelles qui
portent que sur le point qui venait
d'évoquer mesure globale qui doit à
réhabiliter le travail il ya quelques
années quelqu'un qui a occupé
différentes fonctions à
signe l article très intéressant qui
s'appelait quitté d'intituler la
préférence française pour le chômage
c'est un article que tous les
spécialistes economy com vous
connaissent bien il y à une sorte de
tendresse ou de faiblesses françaises en
faveur du chômage
c'est à dire un faux calme puisque c'est
le chômage c'est l'indemnisation du non
emploi
ce n'est pas un état de fatalité donc le
problème c'est l'absence d'emploi et le
défaut c'est l'absence de créations
d'emplois donc s'il n'y a pas un plan
global qui vise à libéraliser l'économie
a allégé la contrainte sur le fait
d'embaucher vous étiez d'accord jusque
là mais c'est reparti dans sa vague à
ses conseillers d'accord mais nous on
fait tout ne va pas du tout je crois
qu'il faut il faut voir la mesure que
vous venez d'évoquer quatre mois contre
l'allemagne dans un plan global ce qui
s'est passé en allemagne notamment à
travers les réformes hartz iv
c'est une réforme globale du travail y
compris des choses très décriée comme la
création de jobs sous payés ou très mal
payés mais qui sont quand même des jobs
qu'on appelle les milliers d'heures
les mini jobs oublier qu'au mondial
allemand a eu nos héros jobs jobs un
euro ça quand même représenté des
millions de gens c'est discriminant
peut-être mais il vaut mieux pour un
être humain et pour l'économie générale
avoir un emploi que pas du tout donc
pour terminer ou bien on envisager sont
globalement y compris d'ailleurs la
durée de travail des actifs ou bien la
leur si c'est encore ponctuelles ça ne
donnera pas de résultats
alors je vais vous montrer d'autres
d'autres éléments pour alimenter notre
réflexion vous faisiez la comparaison
avec avec l'allemagne christian mas
quaregnon la durée de le plafond pardon
d'indemnisation du chômage est aussi
beaucoup plus bas en allemagne qu'en
france
en france ça peut aller jusqu'à six
mille six cents euros par mois
évidemment ça dépend de votre salaire
antérieur mais en allemagne c'est assez
clairement plafonné on vous pose la
question sur twitter d'ailleurs est ce
que vous êtes favorable à une révision
du plafonnement de l'allocation chômage
et vous êtes une majorité 64% à répondre
oui et puis troisième élément que je
porte à votre connaissance avant de
continuer ce ce tour de table
la durée de l'indemnisation là on a pris
un autre exemple celui du royaume uni
qui est beaucoup plus sévère entre
guillemets qu'en france puisque en
france on peut être indemnisé jusqu'à
deux ans alors que royaume uni ça se
limite à six mois thomas guénolé quelque
chose me dit qu'on n'avait pas forcément
envie que la france s'aligne sur ses
voiles sur nos voisins en tout cas sur
ces sujets là si je peux me permettre
il ya un problème de méthode c'est que
selon le selon le critère que vous
prenez vous prenez un pays de
comparaison les différents et donc quand
si on raisonne au global sur l'ensemble
des critères que vous prenez et qu'on
compare à la moyenne européenne
en réalité nous avons certains
paramètres sur lesquels nous avons fait
d'autres choix vous le mentionnez tout à
l'heure par exemple la durée de travail
exigée pour avoir des allocations
chômage est plus faible mais il
yad'autres d'autres sujets sur lesquels
les critères sont en réalité pour être
plus dur c'est par exemple les formes de
dégressivité par exemple à quel moment
devient en fin de droits par exemple le
fait qu'aujourd'hui un chômeur sur deux
alors jouons vous parle
un chômeur sur deux n'a pas
d'allocations chômage du tout donc il
faut garder ça à l'esprit
il ya plein de chômeurs qui sont juste
hors rsa alors pour vous répondre
demandeurs d'emploi oui pour les
chômeurs je meure pas yach aux clients
inscrits pôle emploi qui à chômeurs
chômeurs c'est plus large nous sommes
d'accord je continue naturellement
et j'ajoute juste que pour avoir le
tableau complet parce que délibérément
on a simplifié les choses pour avoir des
éléments les plus percutants où l'on se
rapporte au figaro économie de ce matin
ou au figaro.fr dans lesquelles il ya la
comparaison entre six pays sur les
critères que qu'on a dit oui je vous
reproche pas le fait nos premiers
éléments il n'y a pas de problème avec
ça je voulais juste et à mon avis il
faut comparer l'ensemble d'un système
d'indemnisation avec celui là avec
l'ensemble de celui de bien même pays
plutôt que de piocher alors sur l'idée
générale d'aidé des réformes qui sont
envisagées
ça me fait penser à quelque chose qui a
été fait en 1367 par le roi jean 2 il a
pris une ordonnance royale pour dire que
le
hummer il fallait les [ __ ] en prison
puisqu'il était coupable de leur chômage
donc vous voyez l'idée de rang de
traiter les chômeurs comme des coupables
de leur chômage c'est pas vraiment une
réforme moderne c'est plutôt quelque
chose d'assez archaïque baissait les
allocations contrôler de plus en plus
les chômeurs etc etc
après les choses par leur nom ça veut
dire que les chômeurs ne cherche pas
assez et donc on va leur mettre
davantage de pression pour qu'ils
cherchent davantage et comme ça ils
auront un boulot sauf que me semble-t-il
ce raisonnement est faux pourquoi parce
qu'alors on vous en parle
il ya deux millions et demi de chômeurs
selon l'insee
et pendant ce temps là selon pôle emploi
dans l'ensemble de l'économie je dis
bien dans l'ensemble de l'économie pas
les gens inscrits les offres sur pôle
emploi dans l'ensemble de l'économie il
ya trois cent mille postes vacants
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que même
si tous les postes vacants était pourvue
tous par miracle le marché du travail
fonctionne super bien
si tous les postes étaient pourvus 88 %
des chômeurs resterait quand même au
chômage donc ça veut dire un que c'est
inutile de punir et de fliquer toujours
davantage les chômeurs c'est inutile et
deuxio que les chômeurs je le répète ne
sont pas coupables de leur chômage alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et là dessus
nous avions la même prémices vous et moi
te dire nous n'avons pas assez d'emplois
nous n'avons pas assez d'emploi est ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors
ce que vous ce qu'on peut faire et ce
que nous on propose vous avez mentionné
ma sensibilité politique tout à l'heure
jean phare c'est le populisme de gauche
bien sûr jeu mais c'est pas la même
chose
j'aperçus frites avec l'autre bien sûr
quelle est la solution populiste de
gauche et bien d'une part vous faites
une relance keynésienne de l'économie
par des politiques de grands travaux a
sondé ben pas plus que les politiques
vous savez parce que déjà il est très
long alors si en plus on lui coupe la
parole moi je n'ai pas fait plus long
que monsieur léon que c'est vous faites
vous m vous faites une vous faites une
relance keynésienne de l'économie par
une politique de grands travaux de
transition écologique puisqu'il est
urgent par ailleurs de baisser des gaz à
effet de serre pour ne pas avoir juste
une de bousiller la planète et vous fait
ça par contre c'est très important dans
un cadre protectionnistes parce que les
relances keynésiennes sans un cadre
protectionnistes ça ne marche pas et
donc vous avez à nouveau une production
française qui est compétitive et vous
obtenez un nouveau le plein emploi et il
faut être honnête thomas gueydier a
quand même un effet secondaire qui est
l'augmentation des prix donc vous n'avez
plus de chômage mais les primes sont
révélés faux henman plus cher alors
emmanuel de waresquiel le pression d'un
public lui-même a dit oui c'est vrai il
faut travailler dire qu'à traverser la
route pour trouver un emploi
alors thomas getin le disais c'est pas
vrai parce qu'il ya moins d'emplois à
fournir que de gens au chômage sauf que
certains économistes vous dit ce qu' il
y à des patrons qui savent que toute
façon ils trouveront pas et donc ils
inscrivent pas cette offre d'emploi à
pôle emploi mais sur le sur ce constat
est ce qu'on peut dire ça sans être
forcément anti sociale c'est vrai qu'on
a on a l'impression de voir j'y connais
rien de maintenant mais on a un peu le
sentiment qu'il ya une inadéquation
entre l'offre et la demande
mon département d'affection qui est qui
et la médiane je crois qu'il ya 15000
postes qui sont non pourvus et on trouve
pas on ne trouve pas le les si j'ose
dire les les clients qui correspondent à
ces postes et donc au bout du compte le
problème est pr mans il est au coeur de
la situation du non-emploi en france il
est il est dans la formation est donc là
on est en train de on était en train de
gouvernement je crois est en train de
s'en occuper
réformer la formation professionnelle à
mon avis la fois de la formation
professionnelle et c'est vrai que depuis
la révolution française est probablement
surtout depuis les débuts de la
troisième république
il ya il ya toujours eu cette espèce du
point de vue de la légitimité de deux
delà de la notoriété sociale de
l'individu il ya toujours eu une
préférence pour des études longues des
études intellectuelle qui paraît-il sont
plus valorisante que les autres ou au
détriment de la formation
professionnelle et de la partie manuel
de l'enseignement ce qui est à mon avis
à tort lors l'on nous faisait des
comparaisons avec l'allemagne il me
semble qu'en allemagne la formation
professionnelle marche beaucoup mieux
qu'en france
en tout cas elle est mieux valorisé et
ceux ci relèvent des mentalités et comme
le français n'est absolument pas
cartésien comme on le présente en
général et que d'écarter est un très
très lointain et vague rock n'est pas du
tout en arrière grand père et que nous
sommes toujours soumis à des symboles à
des représentations à des utopies à un
imaginaire extraordinaire le fond c'est
pour mon l'homme le plus imaginatif au
monde qui peut exister
nous restons
comment dire bloqué dans cette
représentation d'un univers intellectuel
qui serait super si loin aux autres ce
qui est ce qui est absolument absurde
quelques commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux
wang shout sur lefigaro.fr qui complète
ce que nous disent écrit sur ma carrière
en dix ans en allemagne ils ont même des
jobs à zéro euro 80 de leurs ce n'est
quand même pas le modèle à suivre
alors que monsieur babineau nous dit le
marché de l'emploi en angleterre et en
allemagne est bien plus dynamique
c'est d'abord celui là qu'il faut
réformer on va écouter bien sûr le point
de vue de renaud girard mais avant je
voudrais vous faire écouter deux petits
extraits d'interventions récente une du
de la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud et l'autre d'edouard philippe
eux ils ont quelques idées pour faire
des économies écouter tout le monde
n'est pas égal devant le chômage et donc
il faut peut-être aidé plus certains que
d'autres pour ceux qui on part donc pour
ce terme il est complètement barbare
mais une très forte employabilité
pour ceux qui ont des salaires qui sont
très élevés créer une forme de
dégraisser mustang pas de statut mais
une forme de dégressivité de l'assurance
chômage peut avoir du sens rené girard
ont pas clairement ça ça veut dire moins
de chômage pour les salariés riches
ça vous paraît normal non ça ne pas pas
normal parce qu'en fait c'est une
assurance et donc on ne cotise à la
hauteur de son salaire à la hauteur le
saut serait donc on voit pas pourquoi
monsieur par exemple qui serait très
bien payé qui gagnerait
quinze mille euros 1
pas moi après votre salaire aux
figurants c'est ce qu'on dit je sais pas
si on gagne beaucoup beaucoup plus juin
et enfin des popalzai quelqu'un qui
gagneraient donc 15000 et 20000 euros
par mois s'ils payent des cotisations
chômage à hauteur où son entreprise à
hauteur de ce salaire important c'est
tout à fait normal que s'ils se
retrouvent sans emploi et bien il est il
est une indemnité qui correspondent à
ceux qu'il a cotisé c'est le principe de
l'assurance
la deuxième chose c'est que ce que
disait thomas guénolé était intéressant
en principe mais je crois qu'il ne rend
pas compte d'une réalité qu'on connaît
tous on a tous pris des taxis très tôt
le matin en revenant de voyage à roissy
et de chauffeurs de taxi qui s'étaient
levés très tôt ou qui venait des cités
qui se plaignait que travailler pour en
fait un smic qui était assez faible si
vous voulez par rapport aux glandeurs
qui était resté qui étaient restés dans
leur lit et qui ne travaillait pas et
qui touchait les assurances chômage qui
sont à l'évidence extrêmement frau
défaut de ses quelque chose que vous
n'avez pas dit tout le monde le sait il
ya une deuxième chose que vous n'avez
pas dit c'est que nous avons tous
rencontrés il suffit d'aller voir ces
sages orient mais c'est c'est pour ça
que je parle je parle de la réalité
perçue je parle pas des statistiques
parce que dans les statistiques
effectivement il ya beaucoup comme vous
l'avait dit il ya beaucoup de patrons
qui
qui sont résignés face au mauvais
fonctionnement
c'est au pôle emploi effectivement et
moi comment larminat exemple je vais
vous donner un exemple précis puisque on
m'interroge
là je vais faire mon marché et à ce
marché je vois que iain que incroyable
au chez le boucher
je dis mais pourquoi vous recrutez pas
vous affaires sont bonnes les médias
font très mal ça mais je ne trouve
personne parce que c'est un métier
difficile de trouver quelqu'un qui
accepte avec vous savez tous le matins
voilée à faut aller chercher oil de la
viande etc
mais je ne trouve personne donc à
l'évidence
à l'évidence le marché de l'emploi et
les indemnisations chômage sont trop
généreuse
alors c'est pas d'ailleurs la faute de
la gauche ce qu'il faut reconnaître que
c'est giscard d'estaing qui les avait
mises au départ on a beaucoup changé à
90% vous souvenez 1,90 pour toi je vais
en chômage et pas de manière jamais mais
je pense que oui mais je pense que
c'était évident par exemple que quatre
mois pour avoir droit aux quatre mois
trop travailler pour avoir droit au
chômage et simplement une plaisanterie
quoi là il n'ya même pas commenter c'est
tout même si pour tout à fait précis ces
quatre mois dans les 28 derniers mois
j'essaie d'être d'être précis je sens
qu'on ne vous réconciliera pas sur ce
sujet alors j'en ai c'est un autre on va
partir à bruxelles où la commission
européenne a refusé hier le projet de
budget italien pour 2019 le gouvernement
populiste italien prévoir un déficit de
2 4 % du pib
c'est beaucoup trop dit la commission
européenne c'est vrai qu'au départ les
italiens avaient dit que ce serait 0,8
donc il a été multiplié par trois en
quelques mois
écoutez les explications de valdis
dombrovskis
c'est le vice président de la commission
européenne
moi j'aime bien les communes sera bien
parce que j'ai l'impression de bien
parler l'anglais de tout comprendre
quand je les écoute écoutez la réponse
maintenant de matteo salvini c'est bien
sûr le célèbre ministre de l'intérieur
italien est alors en gros lui dit vous
pouvez refuser tout ce que vous voulez
je changerais pas d'un pouce et opel
dispose la rencontre comme héritage sera
composée d'un mât noble nessuno produira
vous pose la question sur twitter a
selon vous la commission européenne
va-t-elle trop loin en refusant de
valider le budget italien
et là il ya une réponse oui après de
près de 60%
rené girard on va s'en sortir comment ce
bras de fer d'abord il y avait cette
image qui est assez frappante quand même
de ce monsieur d'europe de l'est qui
parlent une langue du pays qui va se
retirer
n'est ce pas dans ma préférée qui parle
français ou allemands ou italiens
mais c'est baroque qui parlent anglais
alors que l'angleterre va quitter
l'union européenne est un peu triste
quoi
il faut il faut reconnaître que les
hantent les italiens eux mêmes ont pris
des engagements personne les a forcés à
adhérer au traité de maastricht
ils n'ont pas eu non plus des
circonstances exceptionnelles il n'y a
pas eu de tsunami en italie a pas eu un
énorme tremblement de terre et non pas
une guerre est magnifique il n'y a pas
eu la réunification comme l'allemagne
donc je ne vois pas je ne vois pas quel
pourquoi le le l'italie n'accepterait
pas de jouer les règles du jeu
maintenant je constate aussi que la
commission est très féroce avec l'italie
et qu'elle a été plus tolérante à
l'égard de la france puisque quand même
le budget italien va respecter de keita
de marque de maastricht de -2 3% je
crois qu'il a un déficit de 0 6% mais le
prêt les principes les principes de
l'italie comme la froideur on adopter
librement cet euro librement ces règles
ne sont pas les panzers allemands qui
sont venus leur imposer faut quand même
bien bien bien se tenir donc il faut les
respecter
pourtant ma carrière la question est de
savoir si cette affaire est politique où
il sait s'il s'agit d'économie et de
finances publiques
et évidemment les deux se croisent pour
le gouvernement italien il s'agit de
gagner les élections ou et de continuer
à laval les à gagner et de continuer à
poursuivre sur cette voie populiste et
populaire d'ailleurs et populaire
en faisant de bruxelles et ne sortent de
deux bêtes à abattre et en combattants
bruxelles devant sur l'opinion publique
matteo salvini à l'évidence gagne des
points donc sur les migrants comme
jusqu'à présent mais maintenant en plus
sur le budget sur le budget il y a une
grande différence avec les migrants
c'est que le budget l'italie ne peut pas
faire à s'éteindre de choses c'est la
troisième économie de la zone euro
ça n'est pas rien c'est un pays qui n'a
toujours pas retrouvé son pib de 2008
c'est un pays qui est à 130 2 % du pib
en termes de dette publique c'est le
record après la grèce alors que
l'espagne et le portugal se sont
considérablement redressés ont réduit
leur dette publique
l'italie est dans une situation
extrêmement critique qui explique
d'ailleurs pourquoi salvini et ching kuo
estelle et l'autre mouvement membre de
la coalition gouvernementale sont
parvenus au pouvoir
donc si vous voulez l'intrication entre
ou l'imbrication plus exactement entre
la politique et l'économie lie le sort
italien à la réduction de ses déficits
et présenté bruxelles comme des espèces
dedans pêcheurs n'ont pas de jouir parce
que ça serait si l'italie était dans
l'opulence mais des empêcheurs de se
relever selon les critères nationaux est
quelque chose qui implique la totalité
du du mouvement public italien il y en
italie une situation je crois qui est
beaucoup plus gras matt dramatique et
critique que ce que l'on croit alors que
bruxelles fasse son travail
c'est une chose que l'italie défendre
son bifteck
c'en est une autre de toute façon il
faudra trouver un compromis et je ne
pense pas qu'on aille vers une crise
majeure c'est mon sentiment je vais vous
donner quelques points de vue
d'internautes
one shot qui divise l'italie reste dans
les clous du déficit 2,8 pour cent
effectivement c'est pas 3% et surtout
ajoute-t-il
où elle passe custom ceux de nîmes une
grande partie de la dette est détenue
par les italiens oui alors que le cab
ronito lui nous dit attention il risque
une crise financière et une chute des
investissements dans leur pays avant de
continuer le tour de table
je voudrais vous montrer ces images que
vous avez peut-être déjà vu sur les
réseaux sociaux que je trouve absolument
incroyable ne serait ce que par leur
brutalité
c'est juste après la conférence de
presse de pierre moscovici qu'est le
commissaire européen à l'économie donc
il explique que bruxelles refuse le
budget est là derrière lui on voit un
député italien qui prend ses notes qui
est un député membre de la ligue et qui
enlève sa chaussure pour montrer qu'ils
piétinent les propos de pierre moscovici
ce député il s'appelle angelo chuck cas
ça a entraîné une réaction d'ailleurs de
pierre moscovici dans un tweet on va
prendre connaissance tout de suite en
gros qui dit c'est grotesque
d'abord on sourit on banalise et puis
après on se dit que c'est quand même il
ya une violence symbolique forte et
qu'un jour on va se réveiller avec le
fascisme c'est aussi votre point de vue
thomas et guénolé il ya un risque
fasciste en italie comme le la firme
pierre moscovici il ya deux sujets
différents il ya l'utilisation de
chaussures et puis à la montée du
fascisme en italie sur l'épisode de la
chaussure il ya quelques années vous
aviez d'un journaliste irakien de
mémoire qui avait balancé sa chaussure à
george bush pour protester contre la
catastrophe humanitaire de la guerre en
irak
donc faut pas cook route chef en train
de taxation vous savez c'est simplement
un mode d'expression politique
il n'y a pas ça dénote grâce à des
nappes pas aux maintenant mais ça dénote
pas automatiquement une connotation
d'extrême droite d'utiliser sa chaussure
comme instrument de discussions
politiques
après sur le sur l'existence d'un risque
fasciste banon il ya plus de risque
puisqu'il sayeh les néofascistes font
partie du gouvernement en italie c'est
un fait donc c'est pas un risque
puisqu'il est concrétisée sauf qu'il se
revendique pas comme tel nom mais c'est
assez rare que quelqu'un dont je vous
mets au défi de me trouver quelqu'un
d'extrême droite qui vous dit je suis
d'extrême droite ils vont utiliser des
périphrases ils vont dire je suis un
patriote et c est après mon fasciste qui
s'appelle
non non rien vous vouliez messi mais un
mouvement qui est encore plus fasciste
nuances mais ensuite je voudrais vous
répondre sur la question du déficit
italien
il ya un prix nobel d'économie qui
s'appelle myrdal qui avait expliqué que
quand on est dans une période d'opulence
il faut avoir une discipline dans les
dépenses publiques rembourser les dettes
réduire les dépenses et c'est parce que
ça va bien donc il ya pas besoin est que
quand ça va mal au contraire il faut
faire des politiques de relance et donc
c'est ce qu'il appelle les politiques
contracycliques
et là le problème c'est que la
commission européenne alors que l'italie
ne va pas bien propose finalement la
saignée des médecins de molière c'est à
dire faire des politiques d'austérité
alors que les l'italie ne va pas bien
donc moi c'est ça qui me va pas sur la
ligne de politique économique ensuite je
voudrais pour les gens qui nous
regardent qu'on comprenne bien quelque
chose
le but de cette idée il faut pas faire
un déficit trop important la logique
c'est de réduire les dépenses pour
arriver à terme à baisser la dette
sauf que la dette publique de l'italie
est à combien elle à 132 % du pib vous
savez ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que même s'ils savaient demain par
miracle un excédent budgétaire
rembourser leurs dettes en s'y prenant
comme ça ça prendrait plus de 100 ans
donc utiliser cette voie là pour baisser
la dette
c'est complètement absurde parce que ils
n'y arriveront jamais ou en tout cas
quelque part dans le 22e s'il a aussi
dit raison de plus pour commencer tous
et nous apprenons mais justement la
seule voie raisonnable pour baisser les
dettes publiques c'est la création
monétaire
on est d'accord on aime on n'aime pas
c'est un autre sujet mais la seule voie
raisonnable pour la baisser rapidement
c'est la création monétaire et sur
moniteur c'est la fin de l'euro et
attendait non c'est pas vrai mafieux les
amendes à voir si ce n'est pas vrai
parce qu'à l'heure au grade ce n'est non
ce n'est pas vrai parce qu'à l'heure
actuelle la bce et de la banque centrale
européenne est un rythme de 700
milliards d'euros c'est de 7700 tenir
pendant 700 milliards d'euros de
création monétaire
tous les ans pour faire le rebond efface
toutes les dettes publiques de toute la
zone euro en disant si on consacre sa
abaissé les dettes publiques au lieu de
consacrer sa affiliés de la tunisie
guénolé et manuel valls qui est
intéressant dans ce dossier c'est que il
ya deux légitimités qui s'affrontent il
ya la légitimité démocratique d'un
gouvernement italien qui a dit
d'ailleurs nous on va se
on va s'asseoir sur la recommandation de
bruxelles et puis cette légitimité du
projet européen des engagements qui ont
été pris dans le passé renaud girard le
disait et puis d'une nécessaire
solidarité entre pays de la zone euro
oui et puis il ya notre légitimité de
français je trouve qu'on est assez mal
placé pour créer sur le déficit des
autres et le faire et faire des leçons
de morale étant donné notre incapacité à
réduire notre dette
toutes tendances politiques confondues
depuis 30 ans donc ça c'est la première
chose
la deuxième chose je dirais que cette
histoire se ce bras de fer entre la
commission européenne de bruxelles et le
gouvernement italien est mauvais pour
l'italie est mauvais pour boussole c'est
mauvais bruxelles parce que ça ça je
dirais s'enferme bruxelles dans une
posture de gendarme de l'europe qui
dessert qui dessert la politique
européenne une façon générale et et qui
nous conduit à penser qu'on préférerait
avoir une europe plus politique plus
sociale plus militaire aussi qu'une
europe strictement monétaire et de ce
point de vue je vais un peu dans dans le
sens de notre ami qui m'a précédé mais
je ne vais pas dans son sens quand il
crie au fascisme en italie
je crois qu'il faut l'en là c'est un
historien que je te parles tu vois qu'il
faut faire attention aux anachronismes
et ne pas plaquer des situations du
passé qui n'ont absolument rien à voir
avec les situations actuelles
à ma connaissance selvini n'a pas
participé à une marche sur rome
alors monsieur j'ai dit néofasciste j'ai
pas dis fasciste attention justement
oui mais même la notion néofascisme
jeunes populis oui pourquoi pas de même
dans la connaissance il n'y a pas de
structure militaire parallèle on forme
de faisceaux en italie en 2018 comme
elle existait dans les années 1920 donc
méfiance sur les sur les appellations et
les anachronismes
il ya un commentaire un sur internet
2 un tableau qui se fait appeler plug
and play qui nous dit quand on voit le
nombre de pays où la tyrannie règne
traité l'italie de fascistes me laisse
perplexe
l'italie reste un dernier saut grâce à
faut pas tout mélanger le tout les
dictatures ne sont pas des régimes
fascistes et puis au foie fille née il
ya la dictature il ya les régimes
autoritaires il ya toute une palette
donc dire mais attendez il ya plein
d'endroits qui sont des tyrannies alors
est-ce que vous parlez de tyrannie au
sens étymologique au sens contemporain
est-ce que vous parlez voyez donc il
faut faire attention à des
qualifications alain porte très bien ça
sera le vous êtes notre départ on
l'avalé ces derniers mois nicolas
réalité colibri et quand même une
démocratie où il ya la liberté de la
presse la liberté de manifester ou vous
tous les journaux sont voilà et c'est un
état de droit également où il ya une
justice indépendante
voilà j'ai marie est une démocratie j'ai
bien sûr mais pareil j'ai renoncé parce
que j'ai dit qu'il s'agisse de
gouvernement j'en ai pas dit qu'ils
tally est devenu faut pas mélanger vous
c'est à dire merci chers amis je laisse
le dernier mot à nicole qui nous dit
pierre moscovici n'aurait jamais dû être
nommé à bruxelles et se donner ses
résultats comme ministre de l'économie
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque le la france
aussi avaient des difficultés à avoir
des budgets en équilibre
on passe à un autre sujet la compétence
qui vous est nommé membre de la
commission européenne ou président la
commission européenne barroso ça se
saurait et barroso ont déjà accès
président de la commission européenne a
d'ailleurs président incapable
merci beaucoup on passe à un autre sujet
qui n'a rien à voir on revient dans la
politique française
on a beaucoup parlé ces dernières
semaines de se fier à shiki roues elle
était la directrice de la communication
de jean luc mélenchon pendant là dans la
campagne présidentielle
c'était aussi la patronne du média un
site d'information proche de la france
insoumise et puis elle s'est fâchée avec
l'équipe en place qui lui reprochent
d'avoir facturé avec société trop de
prestations de la même façon nos
confrères de france inter ont parlé de
surfacturation dans la campagne de jean
luc mélenchon là dans la campagne
présidentielle la même se fiait chikhi
roux a pris la parole hier pour se
défendre
sur le plateau de nos confrères au bout
de notre consoeur puisque c'était ruth
elkrief de bfm tv
et voilà un petit extrait de ce cas là
dit pas de surfacturation pas
d'enrichissement pas détournement de
fonds publics
c'est clair ces données je ne baisserai
pas les yeux et pour me faire baisser
les yeux il faudra me les crever c'est
mon caractère
c'est ma façon d'être on ne fait pas
baisser la tête je ne suis pas ce genre
de femmes je n'ai rien à me reprocher
dans cette affaire
donc si c'est ma carrière prestations
médiatiques évidemment impeccable sur le
fond vous avez été convaincus par ces
non pas ce qui est un problème de double
casquette
elle est membre du staff dirigeant de ce
mouvement politique et elle est par
ailleurs a priori prestataires du même
moment ce qui est nommément expressément
clairement formellement interdit donc
elles prétendent qu'elle n'est pas
membre du staff
mais ce n'est pas ce que disent les
journalistes de france info et de france
inter donc là il va falloir que l'un des
deux équipes de ses preuves
apparemment c'est plutôt les
journalistes qui ont raison sur cette
affaire mais il en a mon ami on n'est
pas du tout sûr sûr sûr un problème de
vérité factuelle relais sur un problème
de crédibilité de crédit politique
depuis que mélenchon a fait ses sorties
ce mouvement semble avoir le prix du
plomb dans l aile il suffit d'observer
le dernier sondage d'opinion qui porte
sur le jugement des français et sur le
jugement des militants de son mouvement
concernant l'attitude de mélenchon et il
est accablant il est quand vous prenez
le lectorat pardon oui quand vous prenez
le lectorat france un sommet dans ce ton
âge
la cote de popularité de confiance de
jean luc mélenchon est stable non elle
est sur cette partie dans les flammes
sur cette question la maison de raison
ou tort il perd 15 points et je vous
parle est d'accord il perd 15 points sur
ceux sur son comportement par rapport à
la justice de son pays y perd 15 points
auprès des militants de la française
louise et 7 points auprès de l'opinion
générale donc cette les militants la
france a soumis ce sont des gens
exigeants
c'est les électeurs encore un problème
là c'est à dire que effectivement ce
fait si elle était à la fois dans le
staff
donc comme comme clientes de ce fait
shigeru prestataires qui qui qui
facturait des prestations france sophia
chekir audi non c'est pas vrai bon bah
moi j'en reste là
dans l'état actuel du débat public on en
est là vous avez probablement leur
conviction puisque c'est oui mais moi je
suis candidat de la france est soumise
aux élections européennes donc le quand
je m'exprime dans l'espace public à
partir du gauche candidat je ne
m'exprime pas en mon nom propre je
m'exprime au nom de la france un saut
mise puisque je suis l'un de leurs
candidats aux élections européennes
c'est qu'on allait la liberté de parole
votre parti non mais c'est quoi ce n'est
pas une question de liberté de parole
c'est qu'à partir du moment où vous avez
explicitement une fonction de
représentation de votre mouvement en
tant que candidat vous exprimer une
parole qui engage le mouvement que vous
le vouliez ou non
après il va s'investir drac dans mes
campagnes vous voilà alors au stade où
on en est elle va s'occuper des éléments
de communication qui sont communs à
podemos à la france a soumises dans la
future campagne européenne en dernière
date c'est ça vous avez à l'heure
actuelle je voudrais clarifier les
choses pour les gens qui nous écoutent
parce qu'il ya énormément d'éléments de
manière très éparses
on en est à l'heure actuelle à une
enquête préliminaire sur dénonciation
bien ça veut dire quoi
l'enquète préliminaire sert à quoi elle
sert à vérifier s'il ya matière même pas
jugé coupable s'il ya matière à ouvrir à
ouvrir une enquête pour de vrai pardon
le dire comme ça je simplifie donc ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que à l'heure actuelle les
enquêtes n'en sont qu'à vérifier s'il ya
matière à enquêter donc commencé à dire
est ce qu'elle est est ce que ce qu'elle
a fait est inacceptable à ce que ceux ci
est ce que la seule c'est commencer par
le juger coupable
et ça pour moi ça ne va pas il ya la
présomption d'innocence déjà de toute
façon on est bien d'accord là dessus je
suppose mais surtout j'insiste là dessus
la procédure en est à vérifier s'il ya
matière à enquêter
on n'en est même pas à une enquête
récente récession d'aucune premier point
moi je pense oui que c'est mieux et
d'ailleurs je disais sensiblement la
même chose à l'époque de la sphère
fillon soit dit en passant aussi
j'anticipe une éventuelle questions sur
mais dans d'autres cas moi j'ai toujours
pensé qu' il fallait éviter de faire le
procès dans des bacs publique peu avant
une procédure qui est une protéine
enquête raison d'eux
puisque je vous trouve très respectueux
et je m'en réjouis de la justice raison
de plus pour laisser la justice procédé
alors la csu sens au procureur là dessus
nous avons un problème nous à la france
est soumise
sur ce point là c'est que ce n'est pas
injuste d'instruction qui est en train
de faire cette enquête préliminaire
c'est un procureur or le procureur en
france n'est pas un magistrat
indépendant du gouvernement
il est hiérarchiquement soumis au
gouvernement c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme dans donc il a dit ça en
d'expliquer sa handball mouvement
politique qui va définir les règles de
fonctions ses partisans c'est pas moi
qui les définit je vous dis simplement
ça c'est la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme le procureur n'est pas un
magistrat indépendant du gouvernement et
c'est un problème très très brièvement
parce que oui bien sûr elles choses à
dire et je pense qu'il ya un problème
sur un le viol du droit le plus
élémentaire a le droit à la vie privée
dans le traitement une partie du
traitement médiatique c'est pas du tout
où les journalistes qui ont fait ça mais
une partie moi je pense que on est en
france ici ça ceux qui disent qu'il ya
un lien prix vert pour être maintenant
le singe de farewell jeu simple fait de
soulever la caisse ce genre de questions
on est en france ici et les journalistes
français respecte la vie privée des gens
c'est un principe de base et je suis
absolument convaincu qu'il ya énormément
de journalistes qui sont d'accord avec
moi sur ce point première chose et
deuxième point je j'aimerais qu'on
arrête de s'habituer au viol permanent
complet tranquille du secret de
l'instruction dans ce pays qui est censé
être une protection élémentaire de toucy
donner un si beau en auto mag et d'aller
on va entendre la ville emmanuel de
waresquiel sur ce sujet s'il en a oui ce
qui m'intéresse moi c'est pas tant
l'attitude de mélenchon
vis-à-vis de cette enquête préliminaire
du procureur c'est son argumentaire qui
est intéressant et j'ai envie de le
comparer à l'argumentaire qui avait été
utilisé par fillon au moment de de la
sphère des emplois fictifs à l'assemblée
nationale fillon tous les deux sont
partis sur une une un argumentaire de
type complotistes mais fillon parle de
cabinet noir qui est une expression qui
est un héritage de l'ancien régime parce
que le cabinet noir c'était le cabinet
noir de la poste aux lettres sous le
règne de louis xiv qui est créée par
richelieu par le cardinal de richelieu
alors que mélenchon parle de complot il
ay là ils avancent cette thèse
complotiste du gouvernement et on sent
que à quel point la culture
révolutionnaire l'imprègne parce que la
thèse du complot le fantasme du complot
contre révolutionnaire de l'étranger
pittsburgh les suspects qui vous voudrez
c'est le combustible même de la
révolution française n'y a pas de
révolution sans théorie du complot et je
trouve que de ce point de vue là je ne
juge pas mais il est intéressant de
constater qu'il reprend ses thèses
complotistes qui est un héritage direct
la révolution française ça ça
m'intéresse
merci de cette analyse historique
quelques points de vue d'internautes cab
ronito qui nous dit être client de sa
propre société de communication il y
avait effectivement un problème éthique
war thomas gadenne nous a dit que ce
n'était pas le cas mais en tout cas
c'est un point de vue et one child qui
nous dit elle est compétente en
communication elle est très habile je
trouve bon cela dit sur twitter
globalement vous n'êtes pas trop
convaincu 1 par l'ailé les explications
de ce fief chikhi ruia sur bfm tv vous
êtes 80 2% apparaître convaincu on
rappelle évidemment que c'est pas un
sondage mais un point de vue des
internautes qui sont en train de nous
suivre qui s'expriment librement tout
comme ceux s'exprimera librement tout de
suite renaud girard
oui deux choses et à
monsieur mélenchon qui a je crois quand
même un peu perdu ses nerfs et c'est
assez grave pour quelqu'un qui
prétendait vouloir devenir président de
la république lorsque il a été
lorsque ces bureaux ont été fouillés par
la justice d'autant plus que monsieur
mélenchon avait fait auparavant
la leçon aux autres qui je confonds
nationale et à monsieur fillon qui
pourrait qu'il qui mèneront leur avait
reproché de mal réagir face à la justice
qui demandait des enquêtes sur fion et
sur marine le pen
donc ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que en revanche là
je rejoins thomas guénolé il y à la
présomption d'innocence
il ya effectivement le secret
d'instruction moi je suis favorable sous
qu'à l'instruction
donc effectivement je l'aï les violer
d'une manière systématique et c'est pas
une bonne chose ça remet en cause tout
fin toutes les procédures judiciaires
françaises
attendons de voir mon sentiment quand
même et que cette dame que je ne connais
pas mais shigeru c'est ça je l a pas
l'air d'avoir fait quelque chose de très
grave
comme d'ailleurs comme d'ailleurs comme
d'ailleurs monsieur fillon ne vais pas
fait quelque chose de très grave
est ce que sa femme l'a beaucoup épaulée
a beaucoup travaillé pour son travail de
député à louis lui monsieur fillon
c'est d'évidence est-ce qu'elle a pris 1
un nombre très important de
conversations téléphoniques adressés aux
députés fillon c'est évident c'est
évident tout le monde le sait et donc il
a été victime c'est vrai la nasa
renommant judiciaire que j'aurais
préféré que la sphère judiciaire contre
fillon fut séparé de sa campagne
politique et j'avais d'ailleurs
remarquer que cette justice qui est
parfois très lente avait été
particulièrement rapide expéditive pour
pour une affaire concernant monsieur
fillon qui était quand même qu'il soit à
l'évidence une affaire qui était à
l'évidence minimes
merci renaud girard nous passons aux
derniers thèmes que je souhaitais si
vous en êtes d'accord
aborder avec vous aujourd'hui on parle
en ce moment dans l'actualité sur des
registres assez différentes des pères du
besoin des pères alors non pas sur deux
deux sujets qui ont a priori pas grand
chose à voir
le premier c'est la procréation
médicalement assistée qui pourrait être
ouverte élargie plus exactement aux
couples de femmes donc ça veut dire des
pma sans père et puis on en parle aussi
parce que dans les phénomènes de
troubles de violence à l'école ils sont
nous disent les statistiques souvent le
fait de deux d'enfants qui n'ont pas de
qui n'ont pas de pair c'est le retour du
père de famille dans l'actualité cris
sur ma carrière ça vous paraît étonnant
ou intéressant où ça dit quelque chose
de l'époque en matière de psyché
collective dont je suis pas spécialiste
mais on pressent de le préciser sans
doute qu'il y à une réflexion à mener
sur le rôle de la paternité
et sur aussi l'évolution du statut de
l'homme dans la société par rapport à la
montée des revendications et des voix
des femmes qui est tout à fait légitime
puisque on avait procédé pendant des
millénaires à l'excès inverse la femme
était étouffée donc on assiste à quelque
chose qui est un rééquilibrage marque
images qui se fait mal parce
qu'effectivement le père c'est la notion
si on remonte à la bible contractuelle
de loi c'est la norme
c'est la règle et dans le texte de
chantal delsol publié ce matin par le
figaro on voit bien qu elle fait le lien
entre la dissémination des méthodes de
paternité lié à l'évolution de la
science en matière de procréation et la
dissolution de l'autorité générale dans
la société
je ne sais pas si je ferai
personnellement ce rapprochement là je
n'en suis pas sûr du tout mais il mérite
d'ouvrir une inflexion intéressante sur
ce sujet ce qui semble vrai en tout cas
c'est que la notion même de norme
biologique et de normes légales au sens
de
normatif ce qu'on appelle le besoin
d'autorité répond à une demande très
forte de la société dans ses
fonctionnements globo il y à une
redéfinition de la notion d'autorité à
donner et quand on parle de pma il ya
immédiatement une question de morale qui
surgit puisque la science est capable et
la morale semble être en arrière donc il
ya quelque chose qui se passe de l'ordre
anarchique et je pense qu'en soit sa
appelle des prises de position un débat
une réflexion globale et je regrette qu'
un silence un certain silence de la
classe politique à ce sujet c'est pour
ça qu'on essaie d'avoir ce débat au
moins ici comme à guy delahaye on a
besoin des pères alors d'abord
l'autorité n'est pas automatiquement
quelque chose de masculin demandé à
margaret thatcher demandé elizabeth 1re
d'angleterre demander un certain nombre
de femmes l'autorité manifestement merci
catherine ii absolument le l'autorité
n'est pas automatiquement quelque chose
de masculin
voilà premier point deuxième point le
lien entre la délinquance et pas de père
pour moi il ya une faute de raisonnement
c'est à dire que certes les statistiques
montrent que une écrasante majorité des
délinquants ont un père absent ou pas de
père ou voilà certes mais pendant ce
temps là vous avez en réalité un million
et demi de mère célibataire dans ce pays
et ça donne pas pour autant des
délinquants c'est que voyez c'est pour
moi c'est le même faute de raisonnement
que l'écrasante majorité des femmes des
l'écrasante majorité des prostituées
sont des femmes dont quatre femmes
prédisposerait être prostituée
c'est une faute de raisonnement parce
que pendant ce temps là l'écrasante
majorité de la population qui rentre
dans votre critère en réalité n'est pas
dans les faits que vous soulignez et là
en l'occurrence s'il y avait
effectivement un lien de cause à effet
entre l'absence de père la délinquance
on aurait facile au moins un million de
jeunes délinquants dans ce pays ce qui
n'est absolument pas le cas on est
largement en dessous ça donc pour moi
cette thèse est tout simplement faux
sont en tout cas invalidées par les
chiffres disponibles
ensuite sur la pma qui est donc un autre
sujet on l'aura compris l'île argument
du manque d'un modèle masculin parce
qu'ils auraient pas un père dans le
couple bon faut savoir que pour pour les
garçons ou filles
le modem le modèle masculin le référent
masculin par rapport aux escales
ça peut être le père mais ça peut être
d'autres personnes ça peut être le
grand-père ça peut être un mentor ça
peut être un prof est en réalité nous
tous je suppose autour de cette table on
a eu plusieurs modèles masculins dans
notre vie et c'est valable en fait pour
tout le monde et donc dire que ça
créerait un manque 1 / mental je ne suis
pas d'accord non plus ensuite simplement
sur pourquoi passer à la pma pour aux
pros bénéfice des femmes seules et des
couples de femmes
tout simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une discrimination entre d'un côté
les couples hétérosexuels qui peuvent le
faire et de l'autre d'autre part les
moules les femmes seules et les couples
de femmes qui ne le peuvent pas alors
que question simple est ce qu'une femme
seule est incapable de bien élever un
enfant
est ce qu'un couple de femmes est
incapable de bien il sait tourner en
forme je ne pense pas
merci alors on va écouter quelques
instants quelqu'un avec qui vous serez
pas d'accord d'ailleurs vous nous l'avez
déjà dit au mag est donné à l'instant
même c'est l'une de nos vies de ludovic
pardon de la rochère qui était ce matin
à l'assemblée nationale et qui justement
explique que beaucoup de mineurs qui
passe devant les tribunaux n'ont plus de
père écoutez la nous constatons combien
l'absence de père pose problème la
magistrate dominique marcilhacy indique
par exemple que 80% des mineurs qui
passe au tribunal en comparution
immédiate n'ont pas ou plus de lien avec
leur père emmanuel de waresquiel oui
j'ai pas envie de raisonner en terme de
délinquance par rapport à l'absence où
la présence d'un père mais plutôt en
termes de filiation nous sommes dans une
société qui est une société atomisée qui
repose sur le principe de l'égalité dans
une démocratie de plus en plus
administratives et nous sommes nous
sommes dans des positions
individuellement de fragilité par
rapport à cette démocratie
je pense que nous avons besoin d'une
certaine forme de protection et au delà
de la protection de légitimité et l'a
d'ailleurs la dernière cellule qui
existe c'est cette cellule
traditionnelle classique familiale et
c'est cette connaissance de sa filiation
c'est une forme d'enracinement et c'est
certainement la dernière légitimité qui
nous reste alors que nous avons perdu
toutes les autres et de ce point de vue
là où je suis je suis je serais plutôt
pour la présence et l'existence d'un
père et d'une mère dents au sein de la
cellule familiale même si ça devient de
plus en plus problématique est utopique
et puis cette revendication pma et après
la pma probablement la gpa les très
fortes parce que au fond elle est au
croisement de deux obsessions française
la première est une vieille obsession
c'est l'obsession de l'égalité donc
égalité des droits par rapport à la pma
bientôt on dira pour la gp 1 et la
deuxième obsession elle est nouvelle
c'est l'obsession des revendications
minoritaires
qui est également eu d'émanations de
cette revendication pour la pma donc cet
entrecroisement de ces deux c2 de socle
qui ont une vraie audience au sein de la
sauce de plus en plus grande au sein de
la société française renforce au
détriment ou et au delà des
argumentaires qui ont pu être les miens
autour de cette question de filiation de
légitimité individuel renforce cette
position je pense que cette position
finira par l'emporter
on agira en quelques mots en quelques
mois le côté moi ça va être très simple
parce qu'effectivement je suis assez mal
à l'aise face à ces questions j'ai une
intuition qu'effectivement je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce principe mais c'est intuitif
d'enfants à la carte pour tout le monde
et c'est que donne la science et de
bouleversement en fait de 2,2 des
structures de la parenté qui ont des des
milliers d'années qui est entré bien
fonctionner comme cela mais je pense
aussi à ces femmes qui peuvent
effectivement avoir un désir d'enfant et
qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent et
c'est pour ça que je rejoins en fait ce
qu'a dit monsieur ma carrière moi je
suis en fait je suis en fait assez
incompétent parce que ça nécessite je
pense une très grande expertise à la
fois ci qu'elle psychologique
psychanalytique sociologique et donc
effectivement je pense ce sont des
questions qui doivent être étudié en
profondeur j'ai une intuition mais je
refuserai de répondre comme ça
maintenant pour mettre un petit peu de
légèreté dans le débat je me rappelle
tout d'un coup de deux
de la définition que donne alphonse
allais des lois de l'hérédité joue la
comme vous la connaissez non si votre
seconde place et si votre grand père n'a
pas eu d'enfants si votre père n'a pas
eu d'enfant il ya des chances pour que
vous n'en ayez pas vous même
merci beaucoup ce serait une très belle
conclusion mais on reste quand même aux
internautes parce que c'est pour eux
qu'on fait cette émission vous avez posé
la question sur twitter êtes vous
d'accord avec chantal delsol qui dans le
figaro ce matin fait un lien entre le
l'effacement des pères et cette montée
de la violence chez les jeunes vous ne
répondez oui à 65%
et puis un point de vue parmi d'autres
celui de christophe qui considère que
pas de pair ce sont des repères en moins
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission est très
bonne soirée à tous
à demain pour un nouveau point de vue
bonsoir
[Musique]